[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 78 société
tous les 15 jours je vous proposerai un
débat autour d'un thème de société sur
ce qui peut vous préoccuper vous
intéresser ou vous plaire au quotidien
et pour cette première émission nous
allons parler des incivilités alors il
n'est pas question évidemment de la
grande violence mais des troubles de la
vie ordinaire et pour bien comprendre de
quoi on va parler je vous propose
d'abord cette définition d'un sociologue
de la délinquence Sébastien rocher pour
lui incivilité signifie ensemble de
nuisance social extraordinairement varié
qui ne blesse pas physiquement les
personnes mais bouscule les règles
élémentaires de la vie sociale qui
permettent la confiance alors ce sont
des comportements on peut les résumer
comme par exemple des des crachats des
graffitis sur des murs de ville des
dégradations de biens public des
attroupements d'individus des bruits
dans les immeubles des ins j'en passe
c'est des meilleurs j'ai envie de dire
ça il y a beaucoup de types d'incivilité
on va en parler avec nos invités ce soir
on va parler de ces incivilités surtout
des moyens de lutter contre avec vous
Manon de Creuse bonsoir vous êtes
éducatrice spécialisée au sein de
l'association Passerelle Jean-Claude
Duon bonsoir vous êtes maère d'une
petite commune de 6000 habitants
saint-arneou en iveline et vous on
expliquera dans quelques instants
pourquoi vous êtes en plateau avec nous
et la la méthode que vous avez mis en
place en tout cas voilà ho il travers du
syndicat police Alliance bonsoir alors
que d'abord vous êtes d'accord avec la
définition d'incivilité qu'on a vu ah ou
que ça convient c'est vraiment les ce
qu'on peut dire les petits mots du
quotidien voilà variété aussi ouais il y
en a effectivement beaucoup alors je
voudrais d'abord un premier constat un
tour de table sur un constat est-ce que
vous avez l'impression que la situation
va en se dégradant qu'il y a de plus en
plus d'incivilité ou alors est-ce que
les gens sont moins tolérants dans leur
quotidien
is je je crois que il a il y a un
mélange des deux en réalité c'està dire
qu'on vit dans un monde de plus en plus
individualiste qui fait que parfois
c'est extrêmement compliqué de vivre en
communauté et après je crois que si la
définition démontrait assez bien tout à
l'heure ce qui était ce que sont les
incivilités d'une façon générale moi je
rajouteraiis quand même que la
difficulté c'est en fait l'intensité ou
la répétition qui fait que les gens vont
en avoir ralbol ou c'est queun scooter
qui passe en bas de chez vous à 11h du
soir avec le pot d'échappement libre on
va dire ça comme ça ça va le scooter qui
passe 10 fois ça va plus exactement
c'est très bien résumé la situation ouis
euh vous dir quoi je la situation se
dégrade où vous avez l'impression que
les gens sont moins tolérants vous c'est
une petite commune il y a pas pas de
grandes inivilités il y en a malr tout
incivilité comme dans toutes les
communes dire que ça se dégrade je n'en
suis pas sûr euh je dirais que c'est
peut-être l'ambiance générale économique
qui est déjà lourde et qui fait que ces
petites difficultés quotidiennes sont
plus difficiles à vivre et Benon de non
ben je pense que ça dépend des des
quartiers des villes et en fonction de
ce qui est mis en place ce ça évolue
aussi en fonction des des habitants
ouais d'accord avant de continuer à
parler peut-être de parler aussi des des
solutions que vous mett vous allez
pouvoir mettre mettre en place je vous
propose une première séquence c'est un
micro trottoir avez-vous été victime
d'un civilité et lesqueles on écoute les
réponses des habitants de bruit disons
que j'habite dans un appartement et il y
a quand même des nuisance sonore quoi le
bruit le passage à part des motos qui
passent vite qui font du bruit sinon non
oui forcément bien sûr comme tout le
monde plus ou moins des insultes voilà
des gens qui sont mal élevés vraiment
très mal élevé en voiture oui non
quotidien pas forcément mais c'est vrai
qu'on sent que les gens aujourd'hui sont
très perso récemment on nous a piqué les
antennes dans le quartier toutes les
voitures se sont retrouvées sans
antennes radio ah oui c'est un peu
difficile des incivilités on en subit
c'est vrai mais on fait c'est tellement
la habitude qu'on fait même plus
attention c'est un peu terrible qu'elle
dit cette dame à la fin c'est un peu
l'habitude on fait plus attention c'est
dur d'entendre ça quand même ah oui
c'est cl est-ce que c'est quelque chose
que vous vous entendez alors est-ce que
par exemple Manon quand vous croisez des
habitants ils vous disent oui enfin bon
on a habitude hein c'est non c'est pas
trop le les habitants plutôt sont en
colère sont insatisfaits mais ils
s'habituent enfin en tout cas nous les
les familles à qui on a affaire
s'habitue pas trop non alors vous êtes
éducatrice spécialisée vous êtes dans la
rue enfin vous allez à la contact des
populations est-ce que les les habitants
viennent vers vous pour vous parler
justement des
sensivilités alors bah effectivement il
nous parle de ce qu'ils observent dans
le quartier ça peut arriver
effectivement que ce soit pour les
incivilités ou les surtout les nuisances
nocturnes ou ou les dégradations mais
voilà justement ils essaient aussi de
trouver des solutions et de réfléchir à
comment ils peuvent comment qu'est-ce
qu'ils ont comme solution alors ces
habitants en général il faut remonter au
au
mairie et puis du coup C il il ils
essaient aussi de travailler leur projet
pour éventuellement déménager si besoin
ah oui à ce pointl quand même à ce
pointl il remonte au mairie alors ça
veut dire que vous aussi vous avez des
habitants qui qui appellent le standard
de la mairie de saint-arnou pour ce ple
oui oui oui oui qui appelle la mairie
souvent assez tard d'ailleurs c'est pas
dès qu'il y a un problème c'est le
lendemain le surlendemain quand tout est
fini souvent également il y a la
difficulté y a un refus d'appeler les
forces de police de faire le 17 par
exemple alquoi ils vous disent pourquoi
la peur d'être de devoir témoigner la
peur de voilà de de d'entrer dans une
dans un processus qui leur paraît
euh difficile compliqué voire dangereux
euh voilà et vous disiez tout à l'heure
aussi est-ce que est-ce que il y a un
euh un laisser aller en fait il y a il y
a plutôt on sent que les gens baissent
les bras un petit peuin ou alors en tout
cas s'ils veulent résoudre le problème
ils veulent
que les autorités le
résolvent mais il ne ne souhaitent pas y
participer à la résolution du problème
et ça c'est une vra je confirme
complètement c'est-à-dire que on est le
dernier rempart donc très souvent ça
finit par arriver sur le standard de la
police nationale et le vrai débat c'est
qu'ils ont peur de représail par rapport
à des faits précis ou par rapport à des
gens qui seraient connus et reconnus
pour ses faits répétitif et nuisible
vous pouvez pas protéger alors le vrai
débat c'est que bah si parce que je
crois déjà que le premier travail de la
police national c'est le travail de
prévention et donc l'occupation du
terrain c'est c'est c'est la première
façon de lutter contre les incivilités
ça c'est le c'est le premier point après
euh c'est vrai que si on veut aller plus
loin pour quelque chose qui serait grave
ou répétitif euh mais derrière c'est
bien quand les gens puissent
s'identifier et par exemple déposer une
plainte par rapport à des des
dégradations parce que sinon
effectivement sans ça on pourra jamais
effectuer les recherches nécessaires ave
pouvez comprendre que les gens ont peur
deil parce qu'ils vont donner leur nom
ils vont ils vont aller porter plainte
le nom va être connu bien sûr tout à
fait ouais oui je comprends tout à fait
comment fa faire pour les rassurer alors
pour leur dire bah après il y a d'autres
solutions qui qui qui existent il y a
par exemple la vidéosurveillance
aujourd'hui qui est utilisée dans
certaines dans certaines villes ou dans
dans certains lieux publics il y a dans
certains secteurs aussi les plateformes
téléphoniques qui sont surveillées et on
a maintenant très facilement bah des des
un message en fait de de préventif qui
quand on téléphone sur dans le casre
d'une grande entreprise privée par
exemple ou dans le casre du service
public on vous dit que votre
conversation va être enregistrée bon ben
ça c'est un premier pas et la personne
qui subitement avait besoin d'un
renseignement qui serait un petit peu
véhément voir insultante elle va être
freinée parce que c'est que derrière
elle laisse son numéro de téléphone elle
laisse des insultes et donc des preuves
en fait jeanclaud du son la
vidéosurveillance ça vous tente dans
votre commune alors je je jeis pas
expliquer pourquoi vous êtes en plateau
ce soir mais vous êtes un maire d'une
commune de 6000 habitants Satar nous en
Ylin qu'on connaît surtout pour son
péage en fait en vérité pour pour tout
vous dire et du coup euh malgré tout la
petite commune mais des incivilités au
quotidien qui coûtent cher à la ville
une dizaine de milliers d'euros par an
alors c'est des lampadaires qui sont
cassés par exemple et et du coup vous
avez passé un billet dans le bulletin
municipal du mois de septembre pour dire
STOP aux incivilité exactement c'est
pour rappeler le le civisme aux
habitants rappeler aussi ce que coûte
les
incivilités parce que c'est là des
lanternes pour cette année c'est 17000 €
l'argent qu'on aurait pu utiliser à
faire autre chose tout simplement alors
la vidéosurveillance ça vous tente c'est
un un grand débat ça va être le grand
débat des des élections
municipales la vidéosurveillance c'est
un outil et un outil il faut savoir
l'utiliser l'utiliser correctement et ça
ne résout pas tout ça ne résout pas tout
dans toutes les situations je crois que
avant tout il faut responsabiliser
rappeler les règles responsabiliser les
les
habitants euh on a on a fait une
opération avec la gendarmerie parce que
sur mon territoire c'est la gendarmerie
qui est
présente notamment la destination des
des anciens sur plus les problèmes de
vol et cetera mais mais peu importe une
des des solutions c'est de parler à son
voisin parler à son voisin faire
connaissance avec les personnes qui sont
dans le quartier c'est un moyen aussi de
de nouer des contacts et d'être un peu
attentif les uns avec les autres et ça
ça permet en toute simplicité d'abord
par la peur la peur n'est aussi de de
non connaissance exactement et de
l'isolement il y a des personnes qui à
saintternou vont travailler très loin on
1 he et3 2h de trajet aller et puis
retour encore et donc qui ont peu de
temps à
consacrer aux associations mais aussi à
leurs voisins et ça c'est dommage parce
que ça permet de de créer du lien et
donc de freiner c'est c'est difficulté
surtout dans une petite commune comme la
nôtre je présume que ça ça vous c'est
une un avis que vous partagez m de
creuse le dialogue c'est un important
dans ce type de situation quand il y a
des des incivilités comme ça qui gênent
la vie au quotidien c'est important de
dialoguer mais comment on peut dialoguer
alors voors en tout cas en ce qui nous
concerne dans le travail de prévention
spécialisée qu'on fait à guancour et
malivamo bah du coup nous on a une place
particulière puisque on accompagne aussi
les jeunes dans leur démarche donc c'est
aussi en général il nous accorde une
confiance par rapport à ça et du coup
c'est important aussi que les les jeunes
enfin les les jeunes et les familles
puissent exprimer le malêre donc en
général les les incivilités ou les
dégradations c'est un signe d'un
malettere plus profond qu'il est
important de enfin qu' il est important
du coup de leur permettre de verbaliser
le leurs difficultés donc c'estd que
quand vous allez à la rencontre des
jeunes vous croisez aussi les habitants
et vous essayez de soit tis c'est un
lien entre eux ou essayer de les c'est
un peu compliqué c'est plutôt sur des
projets on s'implique sur des projets en
partenariat avec les mairies ou les
bailleur et du coup effectivement on va
chez les donc il y a eu plusieurs
projets qui ont été réalisés donc il y
en a un notamment effectivement où on
allait à la rencontre des habitants avec
des jeunes et où cette rencontre créer
un lien effectivement et et ça
fonctionne c'està-d que au départ je
présume que les gens ont peut-être un
peu d'appréhension voilà effectivement
il y a une certaine des deux côtés hein
je dis pas que du côté des habitants je
penseussi pour les jeunes c'est ou al je
dis les jeunes parce que nous on
travaille surtout avec des jeunes de 11
à 25 ans et des familles voilà
effectivement il peut y avoir une
appréhension don certains ont pas
souhaité d'ailleurs participer à ces
projets là mais en tout cas pour ceux
qui ont souhaité participer ça é
positif ça ça me permet de rebondir sur
le le fait en matière de de prévention
que la police nationale et les forces de
sécurité d'une façon générale en France
sont souvent associés au système
répressif et que la police nationale
contribue aussi à travers des actions de
prévention notamment la demande des
chefs d'établissement scolairire et bien
des interventions qui se font dans voilà
je pense plus particulièr en matière de
lutte contre les stupéfiant mais aussi
en matière de de police routière et là
bien ça permet passer quelques messages
subliminaux à destination de de jeunes
public voilà qui sont scolarisés ouais
parce qu'en 99 on a l'état a lancé la
police de proximité puis ça a été euh
généralisé en 2003 et puis maintenant ça
n'existe moins c'est c'est le vrai
problème hein de de chaque grand
ministre qui se qui se succède c'est que
bien souvent ils veulent laisser leur
empreunte et euh on a comme ça
millefeuilles de services ou de très
bonnes idées au départ euh comme
aujourd'hui les zdsp mais qui se font B
voilà effectif constant on a toujours
les les mêmes problématiques euh il y a
quelque chose qui était très intéressant
enfin qui est très intéressant pour nous
qu'on aimerait bien développer qui ne se
fait pas et qu'on réclame depuis déjà
quelques années quelle Grenelle de la
sécurité on aimerait bien qu'une bonne
fois pour toutes notamment pour ce genre
de problème mais pas seulement et bien
que tous les acteurs puissent se réunir
et là en l'occurrence c'est ministère de
la Défense de l'Intérieur de la justice
de l'éducation des élus et ça ne se fait
pas voilà c'est dommage parce que je
suis persuadé que ce serait bénéfique
sur ce sur ce type de probl un point de
vue vous partagez en tant que maire de
toute façon pour résoudre un problème il
faut faire parler et partag tout le
monde donc pourquoi pas euh vous avez
dit vous travaillez sur Guill encour et
et manie on va justement partir du côté
de de Guill encour dans le quartier de
de Villarois la semaine dernière un
sujet a été diffusé sur tvfield donc
jeudi dernier ça concernait donc le
quartier de de Villarois alors il est
pas question évidemment de stigmatiser
un quartier ou une commune ici mais
c'est intéressant de regarder ce
reportage donc sur les incibilités et de
comprendre le ressenti des
habitants les nuisances dans le quartier
de Villarois guillancour débute il y a 2
ans une vingtaine de jeunes s'amusent à
moto en bas des fenêtres des cailloux
sont jetés cet été les forces de l'ordre
doivent se déplacer à de nombreuses
reprises le problème c'est qu'il y a pas
de dialogue possible c'est que dès qu'on
demande gentiment d'avoir un peu de
silence ou qu'il puisse un peu parler
moins fort ou pas circuler avec leur
scooter c'est tout de suite on se fait
agresser en fait verbalement c'estàdire
que moi je sors de chez moi on me
demande de sortir et puis puis de régler
ça au point dans la nuit du 13 au 14
juillet une dizaine de véhicules
auraient été vandalisés des poubelles
incendi excéd certains habitants du
quartier lancent une pétition pour faire
réagir les pouvoirs publics munis de 178
signatures ils sont reçus par le maire
de guillancour le maire a pris contact
avec la commissaire de de guilloncour
pour voir un petit peu justement
augmenter la présence de la police
nationale comme la présence de la police
municipale sur le quartier et les
habitants l'ont vu et nous l'ont dit
malgré cette réaction certains habitants
ont déménagé ou pensent à le faire les
aurs la on été re ce jeudi par le maire
pour faire un point sur la situation ces
derniers jours le quartier de Villarois
semble s'être
calmé je voudrais vous faire réagir sur
sur deux points d'abord sur cet habitant
qui n'a pas souhaité s'exprimer à visage
découvert donc ça ça rejoint ce qu'on
disait sur le fait que les gens ont peur
des représailles mais l'habitant qui dit
il y a pas de dialogue possible ça c'est
quelque chose que que vous entendez
maintenant par des habitants voilà si si
je parle avec les jeunes moi j'ai voulu
essayer de parler puis ça n'a pas
fonctionné c'est ce que dis ce monsieur
non enfin nous on entend plutôt souvent
que justement si on va vers eux et qu'on
les gens parl avec eux il y a pas de
probl enfin pour les jeunes en tout cas
il y a pas de y a pas de difficulté
particulière après c'est sûr que si on
les aborde sur le mode de la la
répression c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas
très agréable et du coup ça ça génère
souvent des conflits on parler de
répression làjour au mer qui demande
plus de patrouille de policiers alors la
solution elle est quoi elle est
répressive ou préventive je crois que
c'est un savant mélange des deux mais il
y a une vraie problématique notamment
pour la pour les pour les collègues
policiers pour les collègues de terrain
je not citer l'exemple des tags où on a
en fonction de du degré de gravité on se
trouve parfois sur quelque chose qui est
considéré comme un délit mais non puni
d'une peine d'emprisonnement
c'est-à-dire qu'on a pas la possibilité
d'interpeller et ça c'est une vraie diff
difficult posé parce que des fois on dit
mais que fait la police et ben voilà
donc ça veut dire qu'effectivement si on
a quelque chose de de grave et des
détériorations comme dans votre commune
effectivement là si on le flagrant délit
est clairement caractérisé et il y a
aucun souci mais quand on est sur des
crachats ou des traces au mur ou ce
genre de choses qui sont beaucoup plus
légère c'est plus compliqué et donc
forcément il y a d'autres moyens alors
il y a le contrôle d'identité il y a la
convocation au service il y a la
verbalisation à travers une
contravention mais c'est c'est c'est pas
forcément simple c'est on est un petit
peu à la limiteitant qui va vous appeler
pour un graffiti vous vous allez pas
vous déplacer vous allez dire je peux
pas me déplacer déplacer mais vous
pouvez rien faire l'idée c'est c'est que
la police nationale bien évidemment va
se déplacer et si toutefois il y a
quelque chose à constater elle le fera
bien c'est c'est évident après
effectivement c'est en fonction de de de
du type et de de la gravité des des des
faits et bien qu'on peut se retrouver un
petit peu un petit peu coincé voilà par
exemple un scooter un scooter qui fait
du du bruit en bas d'un
immeuble ça ça ça là il a il y a des
infractions code de la route qui sont
clairement prévues et euh le fait qu'un
scooter pétarade ça se ça se verbalise
et on peut donc déjà premièrement faire
cesser l'infraction parce que c'est ça
c'est ça le but ensuite la contravention
ou pas très bien mais l'idée c'est de
reconvoquer au service avec un po
d'échappement qui soit euh bien et en
état de fonctionnement normal Mad est-ce
qu'il y a des échanges qui se font entre
les éducateurs spécialisés et la police
par exemple est-ce qu'il y a un travail
commun qui est fait ensemble enfin on
travaille assez peu en commun sauf pour
des situations individuelles et après on
participe au CLSPD donc conseil local
prévention de la délinquence ça ça
fonctionne bien les conseil
oui parce que ça permet d'améliorer le
système préventif même si voilà parfois
c'est pas ouais voilà c'est une ESP de
partenariat ludique qui normalement doit
payer mais c'est pas toujours évident
voilà je crois que le bon sens de
l'éducation des parents ou de la
maîtresse qui gronde et parfois tout
aussi efficace dans certains incivilités
que le travail de la police qu vous avez
pas vous jean-claudeon ce type de chose
de conseil local de prévention de la
délinquence sur votre commune pas du
tout nous nous travaillons donc j'ai
4atre policiers municipaux sur la
commune qui travaille main dans la main
avec la la gendarmerie donc c'est les
élus les policiers municipaux et et la
la gendarmerie qui s'associe pour
travailler et aller à la rencontre des
habitants d'accord et vous dit en
préparant l'entretien vous aviez un club
pour les 11 15 ans et vous souhaiteriez
élargir un petit peu plus oui la tranche
d'âge tout à fait oui c'est le le la
partie 1625 ans qui est difficile à à
toucher donc c'est une vraie difficulté
j'ai rencontré d'ailleurs plusieurs
associations spécialisées qui qui me
tiennent également le le même discours
mais c'est une vraie volonté d'aller
vers vers cette ation aujourd'hui c'est
vraiment la TR la plus compliquée 1625
euh alors les jeunes de 16 à 25 ans
c'est on va pas réduire à une tranche
d'âge n disons adolescent présadulte
c'est plus compliqué que l'adolescence
c'est vraiment une période très
particulière où se rejoue beaucoup de
choses et où il y a les jeunes vivent
énormément de changements dans leur
corps et dans leur dans leur tête aussi
donc c'est le c'est vraiment un moment
charnière quand on a pu effectivement
grandir dans un milieu famil
suffisamment cohérent on a moins de
difficulté mais après c'est pas le cas
de tout le monde donc nous on travaille
bon c'est les jeunes de 16 à 25 ans
c'est la majorité des jeunes que l'on
avec lesquells on travaille et c'est des
jeunes qui du coup sont peuvent être en
échec scolaire en grande difficulté
oisif aussi depuis plusieurs années ou
plusieurs mois donc il y a tout un
travail à faire c'est des pour qu'ils
reprennne confiance en eux et puis qui
qu'il puissent investir leur projet de
vie voilà doncon en général les
incivilités ou les les dégradations
c'est surtout des passages à l' qui
montrent un malette plus profond donc
c'est pour ça que c'est important quand
même qu' est il une sanction pour
pouvoir justement travailler avec eu la
réparation qu sanction du coup parce que
il travers au niveau de la police on est
limité en droit en terme de droit un
rappel à la loi c'est déjà un rappel à
la loi c'est déjà une première étape
c'est déjà fait ça selon vous le rappel
à la loi en tout cas pour les jeunes
avec lesquels on travaille effectivement
oui ça ça un effet parce que ça ça leur
permet de se remettre en question et
puis de avec le travail d'accompagnement
qu'on peut faire de verbaliser un petit
peu ce qu' vivent et les aider à
réfléchir à comment ils en sont arrivés
là mais est que ça veut dire qu'il
faudrait plus de moyen juridique
peut-être après la réponse pénaleelle
elle est déjà variée parce que il y a
bien évidemment la traditionnelle amende
quand ce sont des incivilités mais qui
ont des répercussions graves en terme de
conséquen il y a les peines de prison
puisque ça peut aller jusqu'à de ans de
prison pour des des des tags par exemple
il y a le travail d'intérêt général il y
a la la réparation du préjudice subi et
le remboursement à la victime
potentielle donc il y a déjà tout un
arsenal après c'est c'est effectivement
le la difficulté c'est de faire
comprendre à la personne bah voilà de ne
pas recommencer et puis pour ajouter à
ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure il y a
quelque chose d' d'intéressant et qu'on
a déjà largement constaté sur le terrain
c'est que sans stigmatiser mais et sans
vouloir gonfler les faits de de groupe
on a un petit peu quand même cette cette
sensation cor général c'est pas des gens
qui sont seuls on a une petite bande un
petit groupe avec voilà c'est c'est
c'est c'est une espèce d'émulation si on
prend la personne de façon isolée on
peut discuter avec elle comprendre les
choses voà la plupart du temps il y a un
effet de groupe effectivement un effet
de groupe je reviens quand même sur sur
l'âge parce que vous m'aviez raconté en
préparant cet entretien une anecdote
intéressante vous aviez eu dans votre
bureau un jeune qui vous AAZ je crois
cassé un lampadaire sur votre commune et
vous avez découvert un collégien oui
tout à fait ou plus est plus dans les
16 tout à fait oui ouou alors qu'est-ce
qu'on dit à un jeune collégien on va lui
faire un rappel à la loi mais on est un
pe le reçoit Mo je je je l'ai je l'ai
reçu avec sa mère et je me suis adressé
à lui pas à la maman mais aux jeunes
adolescents je je lu demandé d'expliquer
ses c'est son acte j'ai pas fait de
euh je j'ai pas essayer de lui expliquer
que c'était pas bien il le savait déjà
hein mais plutôt essayer de comprendre
la la raison pour laquelle il avait agi
et puis surtout il était en recherche de
solution puisquil devait passer au
tribunal donc là on est allé vers une
solution de de travail d'intérêt général
c'est important aussi qu'il puisse qu'
puisse effectuer une réparation voilà
oui tout à fait r général quand quand
dans la transgression
c'est la recherche d'un cadre la
recherche d'attention donc ça ce travail
est faitf est défin en relation avec le
juge dans ce cas-là
oui ose maintenant d'écouter Alain ja
c'est le maire communiste de de la
verrière il a adressé dans le courant de
l'été une lettre au Premier ministre
Jean-Marc herou parce qu'il était un peu
pas dépassé par les événements en tout
cas c'est une vraie problématique on
l'écoute je suis inquiet pour la suite
pour les mois qui viennent parce que
dans nos quartiers la crise économique
que l'on constate au niveau national est
beaucoup plus forte euh on a jamais eu
autant de demandeurs de logement jamais
eu autant de demandeurs d'emploi on n
jamais eu temps de pauvres de gens en
grande difficulté qui n'ont comme seul
recours que les restaurants du cœur ou
autres et donc des familles entières
destructurés et des enfants qui se
construisent dans ces rapports sociaux
difficiles un mare et la République
c'est ce que j'expliquais dans la lettre
ne peut pas avoir comme seule réponse
sans arrêt la police je crois qu'il faut
vraiment investir
massivement en moyen humain en moyen
financier faudrait aussi sans doute que
du du point de vue des moyens on
mobilise un emprintt national on l'a
bien fait pour les les entreprise 20
milliards pour le choc de compétitivité
on peut très bien investir 20 milliards
pour un choc de la dignité dans les
quartiers voilà pour alge une réaction
rapide vous partagez ce Mo je partage
son point de vue sur effectivement vous
vouz un Grenel de la sécurité lui il
vous aussi un Grenel des Cartier de
l'IDE dans les quartiers ouais ça va un
petit peu dans le même sens je soune
juste le fait qu'effectivement quand la
police nationale intervient c'est que
déjà on a franchi un cap qui est au-delà
de l'incivilité gentille quoi on est
vraiment là dans quelque chose qui va
forcément aller vers le répressif donc
ouais c'est déjà une première barrière
on continue donc à parler toujours des
incivilités je je voudrais vous faire
réagir sur deux actions qui sont lancées
contre les sensivilités d'abord ça se
passe ça se passe dans le quartier du
valiibou à plaisir il y a des habitants
qui font leur propres patrouille de
surveillance qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez l're travers est-ce que c'est la
solution que les habitants luttent
eux-mêmes contre euh contre les
incivilités enfin alors ça peut paraître
une bonne idée mais je crois qu'fin au
titre d'alliance police nationale euh la
sécurité publique c'est clairement une
des missions prioritaires et de ça doit
le rester donc j'imagine que ils sont
pleins de bon sens et de bonne volonté
pour occuper le terrain hein sans doute
nous reprocheront-il de ne pas le faire
suffisamment mais ça fait partie de ce
qu'on appelle l'émission régalienne de
l'État et moi je enfin on y est très
attaché
euh ben non qu'est-ce que vous pensez de
ces habitants qui font leur propre loi
mais en tout cas Quiou c'est une
patrouille si c'est pour effectivement
pour les incivilités ça dépend du
message qu'il
véhicule si c'est à nouveau pour donner
une image négative c'est pas très
positif par contre si c'est pour entamer
un dialogue essayer de trouver des
solutions là c'est plus intéressant je
du son oui il faut faire attention au
dérapage surtout à cela que je pense par
contre ce que je disais tout à l'heure
apprendre à connaître voisins discuter
être attentif à ce qui se passe dans
l'environnement et effectivement aller à
la rencontre de tous les toutes les
populations il compris les jeunes il y a
pas de raison que de ne pas le faire on
Nura pas le temps l'émission arrive à sa
fin je voulais aussi parler des
incivilités dans la scncf avec ces
comédiens qui viennent dans les wagons
alors là c'est un humoristique de lutter
contre les incivilités je vis juste un
mot de conclusion pour pour pour ce ce
débat sur cette F socié autour des
incivilités le mot que je retiens c'est
le mot dialogue c'est ça oui je croisou
ouis oui c'est le mot dialogue parce que
l'incivilité au départ elle peut être
effectivement corrigée c'est sans doute
la première solution euh donc avant que
ça ne s'aggrave donc effectivement c'est
sans doute la la la la première la
première façon de de de traiter le
problème avant de s'enfoncer dans
quelque chose beaucoup plus gra à
discuter à dialoguer gentiment pas
forcément de façon brutale évidemment et
ça peut aussi beaucoup arranger les
choses merci à vous trois en tout cas
d'avoir participé à ce 7 h sociétés pour
ma part je vous retrouve dans 15 jours
et cette émission se veut également
interactive vous avez envie que l'on
aborde un sujet du nhésitez pas à nous
interpeller merci de votre attention
bonne soiréeir
[Musique]
merci